welcome to this video I'm playing
Michael H is Michael Hennigan from from
Britain played him before he seems to
play the Kings Indian is basically a
retired player he does not play over the
broad sense anymore I believe may be a
the obsolete leaked game but no one no
tournaments or anything ok the our buck
likes black side a visa it's one of the
one of the more traditional ways to
combat that bit passive but can play it
also okay it takes it's not a good idea
94 this this trick ok so I'm going to go
for the typical regrouping here
yeah the bishop wants to be on c2 night
on e to
nice taking some time here yeah the
question is 92 or maybe this this year
figures f5 mmm yeah one that I can take
hmm bfgf Bishop h6 Queen h4 check g 3 90
x g3 shop g5
Bishop g5 bishop age 6 what do we add
line not sure if I can if I can do that
okay anyway
it's no no big problem anyway I'm taking
I want to take any way i can play Bishop
see to hear first Bishop h6 Queen h4
check g3 night XG 3g5 bishop age 6 what
a weird line the trip age for the ship
takes dito context d 2 nite x h 1 am I
trapping the night I'm tripping the
night ms Bishop c2 so why can I not take
ok show me just show me why I cannot
take this
Queen h4 g3 night takes g3 now
threatening 94 amongst others and Bishop
takes h6o Bishop g5 Bishop h6 the cross
pin that's the only only a reasonable
move and then I take it take the Queen
takes on dieter checking you 2nite h1
Bishop c21 this stripped should be
winning this line
hmm ok let's see what he's doing him
guys taking lots of time it's very
crucial of course after Queen 84 there
is no way back Teague's so night x and
then Bishop g5 yeah Bishop age 6 if he
could go 94 I take the Queen and I just
have a piece so Bishop age 6 is the only
try in a way but i think i calculated
this right Bishop h4 takes on d to King
takes it takes on h1 Bishop c2 is
writing hmm I have you overlooked this
then then you really did a bad
calculation job this was clear but
Bishop age 6 is the thing to see
beforehand and sometimes this is working
though check so now it is trapped by my
bishop here so i did am i hope right
calculation we can check it with the
computer afterwards so I should have two
minor pieces for the rook pink with
equal pawns and due to the very open
nature of the position I mean this is a
wrong wrong way to phrase it but my
pieces have something to take the five
pawn and maybe the King ultimately
so I'm going to take this and probably
here i am with to support it with h form
pawn takes maluku move and my idea is to
to get f5 as the target 93-91 III
putting everything against the pawn
black resigns yeah for once I did a good
calculation job it's writing well played
yeah maybe maybe I think it it looks
maybe it was really really okay but the
compass is not approving f4f force is
good for black hmmm I wonder I wonder I
wonder ever had this on the board before
this is this gives me some some yeah it
seems like some deja vu is goes on here
look at this this is this is very nice
for black yeah black has a fantastic
compensation here
this is this is very good for black so
this is the point not the tactic but but
but dispositional compensation check
this is ultimately not great I can take
here I also also is playable for black
it seems so the only line that really
was losing is the one that I that I saw
was lucky this was sewn working out
fantastically but he had many many
opportunities especially this f4 pawn
sacrifice would have led to two
fantastic plane so it wasn't so clear it
looked very nice but it wasn't clear
okay thanks for watching